[Music]
Jennifer Garner plays a married woman
whose husband betrays her in the new
film that tribes the palace Verdes it's
one of those tiny tiny little movies
it's an engine that could but garner who
officially filed for divorce from Ben
Affleck and April told us art didn't
exactly imitate life well I'm happy
you're all ready any time that you're
playing someone who is going through
something you have to just figure it out
and you actually believe it or not don't
use your own you might think it really
is a it's separate own fare to get
through you just get into the place
because that's your job and then you
shake it off because you have to go home
and raise your kids so just like any
other time I do a scene with an
emotional as for the scene where
Garner's character finds out about her
husband's affair director Emmett Malloy
tells us just how emotional things got
while filming everybody really went for
it and we just got to kind of channel it
and go with that scene in particular I
know that Jennifer said she popped a
blood vessel so that kind of sums it up
but she just joined the crew and was
really with it and didn't have a trailer
and just sat there every day in that
house and did scene after scene and so
then she was just more like a great
partner with us through it all the
mother of three is now channeling all
her energy on her new action movie
focusing her time on fitness
oh man and it's a ruby diet I really
loved a story in the script and I'll
start it next month
[Music]
you